welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hesham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by marcus
godbold who is a senior manager within
the thor engineering team
marcus started his recruitment career
eight years ago straight out of
university he worked at one company for
12 months before then joining thor
companies he was their 10th hire and
then now um a business of just under 100
people so we joined thor companies at
the very early stages of their business
journey and over the last seven years he
has accelerated his recruitment career
from consultant all the way to senior
manager and he is now responsible for 23
consultants and the growth of the
engineering division marcus thanks for
joining me on the podcast
thank you very much for having me here
so
where we always like to start
is with a question i think
you're always thinking about when hiring
for your teams and that is in your
opinion what characteristics and traits
do you think make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant
so i think the first thing for me is
somebody's able to build relationships
and you know i'm not just talking about
the relationships where
you're taking clients out into the the
city to take them to dinner or anything
like that i think what i'm talking about
is being able to show genuine care and
compassion to people that you're trying
to help um you know i think a major
thing for me was i always try to start
and end conversations that i have about
business
with something personal and about what
they like and
get on a level with that person and i
think that that's something that's
really really important to me and what i
pride myself on and what i look for when
i'm hiring future people i think the um
the second thing is that somebody's a
good listener and i think the reason
being is because when i first started in
recruitment and i think at school and
everything like that i i wasn't actually
the best listener as a person um
however i kind of learn how to be you
know i have to write things down read it
say it sometimes to
really like have that three or four
times repetition
and i think when i started to do that a
lot better i started to get a lot better
so you know when somebody is coming into
the team i always make sure they can
repeat information i'm saying or i
understand how they can do that
basically so to summarize relationship
building and listening are two really
really important aspects i think that
any recruiter needs i love that
interested in the first point there how
how do you look for that in people like
how do you find that out about them how
do you find out if they're someone
that's compassionate like in in the
interview environment out of interest
how do you typically try and find that
yeah so i think that um
one thing that i've always prided myself
on is that no matter what kind of room
i've sat in you know i've
whether it's with a 50 year old ceo or
whether it's um you know a candidate
who's the same age as me or something
like that i've always been able to adapt
to that kind of environment and
i think the um one reason for that is
when i was younger i was very exposed to
lots of different
um
adult environments if you like you know
my dad played football my mom's friends
were always over we had a lot of
relationships with adults and you know
there was a lot of times when i had to
kind of sit around a group of adults and
and behave
in that sort of way and i
i like to um
you know
deep dive into what other people that
i'm trying to hire have been exposed to
in that regard as well so you know have
they only been to school and if they've
only been to school and only been to
university and all the friends and
people that they've hung around with
have only been their age you know how
likely is it that they're going to be
able to hold a room with people who are
a lot more kind of senior than them and
behave on the same level as them and you
know really meet them
at that level so um yeah i really like
to understand that about a person and um
you know what their kind of upbringing
was like in that regard
interesting
so
really excited to unpack this journey of
yours and the journey that you're
sticking on so just to to frame this up
so
obviously uh graduated from the
university of whole
from what i can see so sport and
exercise right yeah um if human your dad
maybe had a bit of an influence on that
if you like football and stuff like that
yeah he was uh he played football for
norwich so oh really nice i i wanted to
follow in his footsteps but uh
neville was quite good enough
really
oh yeah
did that did that kill you a bit
no i mean
no i think it's obviously the dream when
you're a kid but you grow up when you
hit you know 17 18 years old and uh
realize that it's not going to happen
[Laughter]
just so so what what i was going to say
but i want to ask you a question about
your dad very quickly but so obviously
graduated there then obviously got into
um
um
yeah so and then you got into
recruitment right yeah um so can i just
talk very briefly around the first year
before then obviously really unpacking
this
really amazing journey that you've been
on from yeah being a temp company to now
being a business that's around 100
people
but yeah very quickly just because i'm
curious
like
what what was it like
to be surrounded by someone so talking
about your dad who clearly would have
had high standards
like obviously that like for him to be
at that professional level
yeah that takes a lot right a lot of
commitment potential sacrifice maybe
would have seen him working
hard putting like what would you say
were the main things
looking back or taking a step back would
you say that you took from your dad that
you think
has really stuck with you or maybe what
he showed you that has really stuck with
you think that's maybe showed itself up
in the professional world for you yeah
definitely so i think when um when i
played football um you know i used to
basically stand on the left wing and be
really good at crossing um yeah and i
didn't ever really want to tackle that
much or you know get stuck in and uh
my dad was the opposite to that i think
you know played right back and um
you know he was always like um you don't
have the
um you don't have the drive you don't
have the guts you don't have the you
know the softer parts um
to really really make it as a footballer
and um obviously that's quite a tough
criticism when you you know 14 15 years
old but i think someone told me that
from quite an early age
um
really hold you in good stead for the
future because you know that's your
development area at an early age and you
want it even better and i think that
when i grew up and realized that i
wasn't going to become a footballer or
anything like that i realized that when
i played football
in the future you know i'd have to have
that drive the motivation the uh you
know i need to mean it i need to
um really give it all i've got and all
that sort of stuff rather than just
thinking i could stand on the wing and
chuck balls in the box what's going to
happen but actually you know get my
hands dirty a little bit and i think
that that was that was great um
and he uh
he uh was managed by a really
hard bastard
he was uh a bit of a slave driver so you
know some of the criticism i came in for
from him was pretty tough but you know i
think it helped he was also in sales as
well when he quit playing the football
um
so i think yeah so i think that that
that helps you know he's got some
empathy around what i've been through
and stuff like that so that was a good
influence
did you have i feel like
you getting that feed like do you feel
like you had the point to prove then
well no dad like i do have grill i can
like i don't know did you have a bit was
that part of what
maybe
i think so i think so maybe
subconsciously it's not something you
know i kind of went into and thought
about you today like i want to prove my
dad wrong or anything like that it was
more the opposite it was like i want to
make him proud um yeah nice you know
and that was the that was the main thing
i think um and you know i think
when i uh i used to help him out when i
was 17 18 years old you know collect
footballs at this uh at this refereeing
thing um that he used to do and you know
i basically used to sit on the floor
sometimes um while i was like about to
collect footballs and he was just like
stand up you're on the job people know
you're getting paid you need to show
everybody why you're getting paid and
you need to be on it and i think that
that was a really good lesson as well
yeah i love that thank you thank you so
much
for sharing that
yeah absolutely um so
always interested to hear about
first year recruitment because you you
typically always hear from people and
i'm sure you communicate this in your
own way now like it is a difficult part
of your recruitment journey and these
things so
obviously from from what we consider to
work to one company for a year and then
then obviously you've joined thor
companies and it's been a real success
although there's been plenty of bumps
along the road so like just talk to us
about that first year then like
how do you describe your first gym
recruitment coming straight out of
university
yeah so i'd say my first year
recruitment was
pretty horrific
um
i uh i really really struggled i think
with a couple of things i think firstly
you know the environment was tough you
know if you're at the bottom you were at
the bottom and you were treated that way
in a way and you know obviously you get
the training and and you know certain
people in the team are nice but you know
you can just tell
from everybody else in the business how
they're viewing you
and then i think um
uh it was so kpi driven very kind of um
[Music]
which works for some people but it
didn't necessarily work for me
um you know i was hitting the numbers
and i was doing what i was getting told
and the only feedback i was getting was
you're doing what you're being told it
will come it will come
and um
you know i think the reason why i stayed
in the business for a year having only
done two deals was because i was hitting
all of my kpis
but i wasn't getting the
attention where it was just like cool um
your calls are going like this
i had some really good call coaching by
an l d person and that was great but
what i didn't have was the strategic
knowledge of where to focus my time you
know i was spending some time in poland
in south africa in
you know
timbuktu wherever trying to do deals and
you know when it came to the crunch it
wasn't necessarily
ever going to happen because the rates
were too low or there was withholding
tax or anything like that and you know
the feedback i kept doing i kept getting
was just keep doing what you're doing
and um
i um
yeah i think i got a bit fed up of that
um
and
i thought about leaving recruitment all
together to be honest um
you know i started with 14 people in the
graduate academy i was one of only two
left so i didn't feel like i was the
only person who felt like this and i
felt like i had some unfinished business
really um because i saw other people who
were looking who were working around me
and um you know i thought they were good
good people they were good at what they
do but i always thought i could have
been better to be honest and i thought
that people could i could build
relationships better than the person
next to me who was doing really really
well
um and i was just like i'm not really
willing to waste a year of my life
having done this and come away with
absolutely nothing because i did two
deals but i didn't make any commission
in a year
um
so
um yeah but
in hindsight i would say it's literally
the best thing that's ever happened to
me
it really is and i think that um going
from university where you know you feel
like you're a big fish in a
in a um a small pond and you know you're
in the au and playing football and all
that [ __ ]
um you know it doesn't really compare or
prepare you for what you're about to go
into and i needed that shock i think to
whip me into shape a little bit yeah
so there's a couple of things that i
will not ask you here so
one i think you sort of touched on it a
bit but just just interested to hear
like what two deals in that year didn't
make any commission like why didn't you
quit
i think it partly was because of the
point i saw other people doing really
well who i thought it could be better
than yeah secondly it was um yeah this
point i didn't really give up leaving
with nothing um and i think third was
thor and um
the
interview that i had with uh nick and
chris the directors
um it was a brilliant brilliant
conversation one of the best i've ever
had and you know the i thought about i
applied for so many other jobs like four
or five other jobs in hr and internal
recruitment and that sort of thing but
um i had a chat with them and their view
of recruitment was exactly what i
thought i was going into when people
were describing it to me before
university
very quality driven very relationship
driven you get to go and meet your
clients you know you get to
actually spend time on your interviews
and nurture them and prepare them
properly and you know
not just be driven by stats all the time
and um i think that also made me think
actually you know maybe a smaller
environment where i can learn off these
guys will be a lot better suited to me
yeah that makes sense
and then the other thing that i just
wanted to get your thoughts on i've been
uh recording like a sort of graduate
stroke entry-level focus podcast series
in the past couple of weeks
so obviously you've been on that journey
as you said like you felt like in
hindsight is actually the best thing
that ever happened to you needed that
shock so
i guess with hindsight anyone listening
to this that at the moment may have just
graduated or is currently going through
that process of interviewing
recruitment businesses or consumer
recruitment as a career like what
what would you say to those people in
preparation for that first year
knowing what you know now
i think stick with it at the end of the
day the job gets easier the longer that
you do it
and you know what i've learned certainly
through my time at thor is if you spend
enough time in a skill set
which is a niche where you know your
managers have got a proven track record
that there is deals to be done there
then trust them and really really stick
with it um and you know it may be the
case that after
um you know two months three months four
months you're not doing any deals but
all those conversations as long as
they're good quality and on the right
strategy
um
you know they
yeah love that
so let's unpack this this seven year
journey so far then because
i think not not every sort of um not
everyone goes on that journey where
you're like the temp fire and then a lot
of obviously recruitment companies i'm
sure would have said look marcus this is
where we are today this is where we're
going to be in x amount of years and
that doesn't always come true right so
obviously you attempt fire the four
companies you mentioned around how what
really resonated with you was how they
thought about recruitment how they
approached it
um and obviously they're now getting to
the mark of having 100 people in the
business so
let's um unpack this i guess what
what i'm interested to understand
first and this you may talk about all
different parts of this seven years so
far but i think it's really interesting
the part that you said around you didn't
have like the support and the strategy
planning piece
i'm just interested in that i feel like
you what you're sort of saying is like
having a niche or having a focus
but like how like from that learning
like how have you then made sure that
you you do have that a lot have you made
sure you do have that in the last 70
like what do you actually mean by that
how have you then applied strategic
planning to building out
markets desks helping your consultants
in the last seven years out of interest
i'm just really curious on that yeah so
i think the the first um
the first part was i started with um
working within hseq
um globally and although the niche was
hseq
it was the case that there is
um
yeah like
all over the world like way too much to
go out basically um and then yeah when i
basically moved to thor they were very
focused on norwegian oil and gas and i
specifically just focused on the subsea
engineering sector
and although i still didn't have that
much success in my first year i think
again i did like two deals within that
um
partly because of the the market crash
but partly because i still had a lot of
development areas um i really learned
how to map out the market um understand
how many engineers within which
disciplines are in each company
understand how to ask the candidates how
to get that information and really
become a genuine market expert and i'm
not talking a market expert about you
know what the technical engineering
pieces and what orkaflex is and all that
[ __ ] i'm talking about
tangible recruitment information where
you know
if somebody gives you a job how many
candidates there are in the market that
you can go up and you can say to a
client um
okay great well you need a rigid
pipeline engineer oh right well there's
40 there's 40 people who do that in the
market well there's 42 people who do in
the market of which i've spoken to this
many in the last six months
here's how many people could be
interested so you need to be looking at
a time frame of between three and four
months when this project finishes and
those people could become available
um
that is that is being a market expert um
you know you don't have to be an
engineer to be an amazing technical
recruiter
and i think that when you're able to say
that um to a client right then and
you're not just sat there and just being
like oh yeah we'll get those people easy
when they know it's not easy so who are
you trying to kiss you know people love
the modesty
and i think that that's um what i really
really learned within the oil and gas
sector um when i moved over into my core
market which was the infrastructure
sector in sweden um i applied exactly
the same thing and i think that
the problem was the norwegian gas sector
which was in my first 18 months in thor
was um
the market had dropped off just as i
started to get good and i don't like
blaming external factors maybe i should
have moved over sooner but um you know
like the buying signs weren't there
there were candidates that flooded the
market no one was hiring anymore etc so
when i when i then understood and
learned all those principles and moved
over into the swedish market that's when
it started to really really start to
kick on and and um
i found that that niche and the honeypot
and um
you know i think after doing like four
deals in my first two years in
recruitment and not earning any
commission i then did 48 placements in
two years um
by finding that niche yeah yeah i love
that
um and you know managing people now um
as a company we have to um
we have to basically have people who are
really working hard in our core markets
what we're doing now but we've also want
to have people within a with a growth
mindset and by that i mean you know
people who can carve out newer niches
and help grow the business and one day
they'll have their own team
um and you know i think what i say to
those people is you've got to start off
quite broad and really understand and
smell what sells i don't really ever
seen the apprentice but they have that
market stall thing where it's like okay
that's selling more i loads more of that
um and yeah i think that i i really
really understood that in stockholm and
that's what i really encourage my team
to do basically smell what sells um get
build up your inventory of candidates
you know you wouldn't open a shop
without filling the shelves with
stuff yeah um and then yeah basically
once you've done that then go out to the
market see who could be interested in
which type of candidate and then that
that's basically the niche that you can
go into i love that thanks for sharing
that so a couple of things that i want
to just sort of uncover a bit here so
um obviously you mentioned around the
so yeah you went from like as you said
first two years not having loads of
success to then
like then it going a lot more better or
how you'd hoped your recruitment career
would go right so just for a bit of
context really quickly have you always
done have you always done perm or
contract or both
i've done both
okay cool
so at that time in your journey was
you're doing contracts with pam in
stockholm
um
so the first year was all contracts um
second year in norway was
uh per man contract um in stockholm in
stockholm it was probably 95
um in sweden okay yeah and that's when
you did like just under 50 placements
yeah yeah exactly okay perfect so just
just interested here so like i know you
so you've mentioned so you said like you
took away some of these core principles
i guess i'm just trying to uncover what
maybe some of the other principles are
that you took away that you had to learn
the hard way or the long way in those
first couple of years but obviously a
lot of recruiters listen to this will
obviously have to go on that journey of
like building out their new market or
building out their own client list and
these types of things right so
i guess what i'm just interested to find
out from you i know you were just
talking a bit about it on
trying to maybe start a bit broad
understand what sales build up your
inventory and relationships of
candidates
but like obviously looking back and
maybe you can also draw on your team as
well but like
as as you were building out that that
market like what ended up being your
most trusted way of like building client
relationships out of interest like what
ended up being
you're the most um efficient way of you
yeah um
partnering with clients getting more of
those opportunities because i think
that's typically where obviously a lot
of people struggle or find the biggest
challenge when building out a new market
so what talk to me a bit about your
strategy or what ended up working on
that side
yeah so i've heard it a couple of times
in your podcast but um it's a lot to do
with going to meet people
um
and you know i think the fact that i've
basically been an english person working
in a foreign market
and i've made the effort to
fly to another country to go and meet
people
um has been amazing so
i think in that two-year period i
actually had a look the other day for
one of my appraisals i had 56 client
meetings in norway or sweden and we also
went to six different conferences as
well in norway or sweden and whilst them
living in london
um so that's like you know every four to
eight weeks really really making the
effort to go and see people
and i think that you know when you're an
english person sat in the room and you
know all about the local area and you
know different words within the local
language that kind of really
um you know sets you apart from from
other people so
um and then i think that again when
you're there um you know being able to
be passionate get a bit emotional about
your brand and what you're doing you
know be realistic about the type of
people that you're presenting and and
just be really quite honest like no
[ __ ] sales just you know be honest
and what you can deliver what you can't
people will buy into that a lot more
than you know saying you've got hundreds
of candidates in the skill set that you
just don't um and you know i i've always
worked off the basis that if you if you
show people and if you're passionate
about what you're doing then people will
believe in it and uh
yeah i think that you can only really do
that properly face to face sit there
shake out shake their hands have a
coffee with them
take them for a pint um and then you
know i think that that's the best way to
business to do business development and
conferences i absolutely love
conferences i think they're so much fun
um i think every single recruiter should
have the
um drive and will to go to an industry
conference you know they should
meet people network in the room and it's
it's a really daunting feeling having to
go up to somebody the first time in in
the room shake their hand when they
don't know you and never even heard of
you but the buzz is unreal and you know
the relationships that you can build off
that are superb so
yeah i definitely definitely think that
face-to-face contact is is 100 what you
should be pushing for and i get that
when you're new to a new to a company
they don't necessarily invest in you and
back you back you to do that but um i
think when i worked at thor i said to
nick and chris look i've got to go out
there within the next two months i never
got the opportunity
um
at my old company i really want to go
there as soon as possible so i can feel
it and get a taste of it and um after
two months they sent me out there on a
conference and i was just like this is
so cool i'm in
um you know i i can't wait to do more of
this
so it seems like the answer there is
like you just really doubled down and
invested in relationships
made the effort to get over there really
yeah okay that so just two two things i
want to go into so first i know
hopefully we can get
more opportunities to go to conferences
again really soon which is
really exciting right
but i i just wanted to get your thoughts
on this
what
so like what how do you now approach
conferences that you think gives you the
best chance of like maximizing your time
there so like maybe the way that you
approach the first one it'd be totally
different to like the way that you
approach the fifth one what i'm trying
to find out is which i had to learn the
hard way right when i first attended
like networking events i used to recruit
the insurance industry and i did attend
insurance events like it can be daunting
right and like i think the wrong mindset
which i learned was the goal isn't to
like try and give out as many business
cards as possible right it's more about
like how how can you
sort of try and work the room and make
as many connections as possible by not
always just talking about you and
finding out like asking things about
other people and like like that's how i
then tried to approach things like
like the goal of like having interaction
with someone isn't to talk about
recruitment and isn't to give them my
business card it was more about to at
least get the space to go hey this is me
this is what i do
but to like find out more about them and
why they're here what's important to
them and these types of things like
what's what's been your approach like i
don't know how would you approach
conferences now that maybe you've got
much better at that you feel
gets them to get the most out of going
to these things and connect with people
have you improved on that exactly so i
think within within my industry
specifically um
you know there's obviously suppliers or
subcontractors and then there's clients
right so um you know one thing can't
happen without the other at every level
of the supply chain
um so i and i think that you need to go
in to the conversations and conferences
to be like everybody here is open to
doing business in some form or another
right if not they wouldn't be here um
and at the end of the day some
conversations and some people that
you've got to are going to be more
daunting than others but they're
probably the ones that are going to make
you the most money you know if you've
got somebody who's sat there and really
came to talk for a long long time
and you know they're not necessarily
going to make you any money then you
need to be a little bit short and cut
through and be like i just need to move
on now i've got other business to make
here um in the most polite possible way
of course um but you know be really
disciplined with that and i think that
you know um
some of the some of the conversations
i've had where it's just been like okay
great i'll pick you as a client oh hold
on a sec well you're the director of
infrastructure or director of
engineering for that company you're not
you've got a psl you're not able to use
that's cool what's your situation
could you move and then it's a direct
face-to-face headhunt as well yeah and
people almost you know are taking a
little bit back by that but they'll
remember the conversation and i think
that that is
a really key thing is you know be
memorable at those things yeah you can
give your business card over but um
you know
like
always remember that people are there to
do business and you know there's
people having
policy
exactly i think that's that's the main
message um
and yeah your pitch needs to be good so
you're not boring but um you know i i
think that you can work on that and you
can get trained on that yeah yeah nice
so then the other thing that i know
people will be really interested in
is then like the the culture piece or
the things that you've had to do to
maybe adapt to whatever i know that it
seems like your journey you've always
typically recruited like outside of the
uk
but just maybe you've had more of this
experience with hiring people for your
team and stuff like that but like what
would you say the main
nuance differences in to like serving
like a culture like stockholm for
example or like the nordics i don't know
what are some of the things that maybe
you've had to change or tweak slightly
that
yeah just didn't resonate or work
in the in those types of mods that have
been traced a lot of people interested
in that like how different is it
would this work would that not work i
don't know any any sort of key things
that
yeah big time big time is it's massively
different to the uk i think in the uk
a lot of people know
what recruitment is and um you know they
kind of know the game a little bit by
now and they're already quite educated
on how to use recruiters and what it's
all about whereas um you know in
northern europe i think that
there's a lot of different types of
recruitment companies in northern europe
there's like cd sending services and
database services and lots of different
things so you know it is a little bit
more of an education to people
and i also think that it's a really good
training best for people to be like
you've got one chance and that's it and
you know it will literally be like okay
well we don't like confrontation as much
here obviously in the uk we you know we
love a little um
but there they don't like conversation
as much so if you mess it up
they won't necessarily tell you or they
won't give you a full details you know
you'll all of a sudden have some contact
just being like
um
yeah we're not interested in using you
anymore without that much of an
explanation
and um i think that you avoid that by
you know obviously relationship point
coming up again um but you know
providing them with a good service and
if you provide them with a good service
and you can show them that you're
working hard um even if you know the
results aren't quite there they
understand because it's a candidate-led
market
um and you know the the skills aren't
readily accessible to everybody and um
if you show them that you're working
hard they'll stick with you definitely
okay interesting um and i think i think
like sorry um that's okay yeah
that cultural understanding as well like
you know really being able to
um
know that do you know what if you call
somebody on swedish midsummer
they will literally never speak to you
again because that's basically
christmas day
um so you know obviously that's the
extreme but you know little things in
between is is also really really
important
whatever country you're working in and
then just real short question like
are like are because i think sometimes
people can just think this like
are people like really receptive to like
speak like do they understand that
you're based in the uk typically but you
go over there is that like really like
people aren't like oh you're based in
the uk i want to deal with people who
are based in sweden a lot i don't know
is that a thing or a lot of people
really yeah
yeah definitely it is a big objection
that we get um however you explain the
benefits as to why it's it could be
better than some of the your competitors
who are in country and they love it um
and not only that but i i see it as a
massive strength as well you know when
you're calling a candidate in the city
and you're calling from london and
you're an english person and you're head
hunting somebody and you're using some
swedish terminology or norwegian
terminology or danish or whatever you
have an edge over your local competition
um
and
because it's a little bit it's something
new something novel a bit of flattery
you know it's not every day they receive
a call from an english person
um so say it's got strengths and
weaknesses um in both but i think that
one of the ways we've negated that is by
hiring a lot of um scandinavian people
to work in london and you know then
obviously we say you get the best of
both
so
i think uh that's a really really
important um thing to understand that
don't have limiting beliefs around you
know your language if you're good you're
good if you provide a good service and
you provide the right people people
don't give a [ __ ] where it comes from or
how much it costs you know well to a
point um but you know i think
like it doesn't matter where you're from
it's just very good thanks for being
pretty candid about that yeah it's like
it's easily something that you could
tell yourself as to why you could then
expand your desk or like crack that
market you know what i mean but and
that's why we're having these
conversations and
so look what i'm really keen to do
over the next sort of 15 20 minutes and
it's just like i really unpack this
leadership journey of yours because a
lot of recruiters listen to this will
definitely be aspiring leaders and that
can sometimes be like a really difficult
path
but before we do really quickly just
because we're talking a lot here around
like marcus building
a desk having more success these types
of things just another really popular
area we spoke about new business we're
speaking about the nuances of yeah
working um
europe european market
but really interested to hear your
journey with day plans
and structure
it's just a really popular era like
people are interested in like what what
does marx's typical day plan like that
he feels gives him the best chance of
like maximizing your working day getting
the most out of your activity and i'm
sure this is something that you help
people in your your team with now but
like when when you were like really yeah
like smashing in the deals like really
at the peak of like really building out
your core markets and stuff like i guess
what were the non-negotiables
surrounding marcus's typical day that
you felt like enable you to get the most
out of what you were putting in
yeah that this is um a really hot topic
for us at the moment actually i did a
training session on this yes
nice and fresh so i think um
and i had one of your other podcasts
where it's just like so ridged and so
planned um yeah i i wasn't really that
type of recruiter and
i i see a recruitment day as two
different things i think one is
high level and reactive tasks so by that
i mean like you know going from closing
deals offers outstanding second stage
feedback second stage interview requests
first stage prep all of those things
which is to do with your interview
processes okay i don't think you can set
a specific time of day unless you've got
a booked in call around some of those
things right but they're things that you
want to tick off throughout the day i
think after that you then have open
tasks all right and then open tasks
around what you're doing proactively so
if you need jobs it's business
development around cvs that you've
specced out around leads that you've
generated around or whatever um
or it's an open task around cool i've
got three jobs at the moment in two
different skill sets i'm gonna spend um
you know this much time you know three
hours in the afternoon on those two
because obviously there's a better
chance to place if there's two and then
i'm going to spend you know an hour and
a half on that that last one all right
um and then that that's
kind of
um
balancing your day versus the
opportunities and commitment that you
have is how i see that
then afterwards so this is something
that we're massively hot on at the
moment is that um you need to have your
day pan done for the next day and you
need to have a
have marketed out
you know candidate singles and emails
and linkedin messages and all that stuff
to fuel your day for the next day um and
also send out any spec cvs or floats or
whatever right the end of the day and
that's kind of like a daily checklist
that we've got going on at the moment
nice i think what's really important is
to have a target each day
right and have you know
not necessarily a strict set of kpis but
you know i want to
achieve this in terms of my proactive
work right and this is what i can
definitely affect however what my goal
is is to get a cv in for this job today
and do you know what i could do this
part amazingly well but
that part you know i i can't necessarily
affect as much as th that part so i'll
focus on that part and that part will
look after itself
um
so yeah i'd say that i i've i may be a
little bit more flexible and follow my
nose and that sort of thing
um
more than other recruiters but i i um
and i'm not so rigid but yeah that's
basically how i like to look at things
open tasks and close tasks thanks for
sharing that i think yeah really common
theme something i always big advocate on
because it had such an impact is
yeah if you're not if you're listening
to this and you're not starting your day
before it starts do change that so like
you said understand before you come into
the office before you go into your
office tomorrow like what you need to be
focusing on etc really like the addition
that you just said like setting your
future day up
for success so like doing those things
that could mean that you get more
traction the following day like you said
the linkedin messages things
and then what i really like with what
you said which is something i definitely
need to improve on but has also come
from some of the sessions that we've
been doing in the recruitment mentors
platform recently on this
obviously the added benefit of like
adding a target so for example like you
said if you blocked out two three hours
on bd or candidate sourcing for a
particular job like the great thing
about also setting a target in those two
to three hours is that one you can
actually see how you did rather than
like finishing that time and going oh
how did that actually go because
sometimes you can feel like that kind of
like how good
how well did that go
and then the other great thing is then
you can reflect on it you can review it
so like if you if your target was to to
um speak to five hiring managers and you
spoke to free
part of the end of your day or at the
end of the week which i really recommend
is then having some sort of
self-reflection review of like how did
the week go whatever you can then review
those things and go right why didn't i
speak to five hiring managers well i
didn't get my i didn't get my call list
planned that definitely had an impact
and like if you have those targets you
can then give yourself space to be like
right what am i going to do next time to
make sure i do hit the target rather
than just having the block time i think
exactly condition yeah
100 agree and you've got to have enough
of a sample of what you're doing to work
out what's going wrong and at the end of
the day if you're only calling 10
candidates a week and you're getting no
cvs in then
you know you your
um
understanding of your skill level and
the reasons why is going to be so much
less if you just absolutely went for it
made 40 calls and then actually could
pick up a trend of um you know okay
great well
that person missed roe so i need to work
on my commitment for um roe um so i'm
massively on board with that you know
sit and reflect on on the day before
have a look at your targets um i think
the other thing that's good to mention
around day plan is um
what you're doing before you get to the
office
right because i i
i can't remember which podcast it was
but i i listened to something it was
just like you really need to warm your
brain up before you get into the office
and you know i know uh i've been guilty
of it in the past that i've been just
sat there mindlessly playing on city
manager and you know for my for my
commute for 45 minutes but you know what
i actually did in the end was started um
doing some duolingo um for swedish words
on my phone and and that basically gets
your brain into gear either that or go
and go for a run you know get your
endorphins going get your exercise going
get blood to your brain and i think
that's another way to to really kind of
stop this really slow start when you get
to the office um you know i had a girl
say on your podcast as well that um you
know i want to make sure that when i
come in i'm half an hour before my
competition and i'm on it and uh yeah i
thoroughly believe that you know you
shouldn't be waiting until 9 9 30 to
start making your first call you should
be on it straight away and the best way
to do that is really warm yourself up
and get the blood pumping basically yeah
yeah for sure
right so
we okay for time like the final like
last next 15 minutes i just want to talk
to you about your leadership journey is
that okay yeah go for it okay cool
so
obviously obviously we spoke a lot
around the billion piece and then
obviously like we um spoke about before
we started this and then it seems like
you've been on then a sort of leadership
journey for the last
five years or around about that so as i
said in the introduction you you now
you're responsible manage 23 consultants
um i guess let's just go into the stuff
that maybe a lot of people can learn
from like what what were some of your
maybe one to three biggest challenges
going from like marcus the biller just
worrying about marcus's billings
performance to then
being responsible for other people
that's obviously grown the amount of
people but like what have been some of
your biggest challenges that you've had
to work through that maybe people could
learn from that you've had to work for
on this leadership journey
yeah i'm absolutely not ashamed to say
this because i think it's a massive part
of the journey that any manager will go
through but obviously when you're
billing doing deals you know you're the
one banging the gong or ringing the bell
and your deal students played or
whatever it is and then you kind of go
from that to a little bit in the shadows
um and letting other people take the
limelight a little bit and um i've got
to admit that you know i'm somebody who
you know likes to be
um
you know it's in the limelight and likes
to get recognition all that sort of
stuff and then when all of a sudden that
started to taper off
and you know i i wasn't going on club
lunches for deals but i was managing
people who were
you know a little bit of jealousy crept
in but
you do have to get to the point where
it's just like okay grow up a little bit
you know it's not about you anymore
you've had a really good journey where
people have taught you and you know
built you up to the point where you've
got to this place so now you need to do
that for other people
um
and i think yeah that that was just
a bit of growing up basically and
um having a word with yourself
i also think that secondly i'm i'm quite
an emotional person you know i think the
textbook on recruitment is
um you know stay flat line you know
never get never never let the highs
yeah i'm not that guy and i don't try
and be anyone different really um you
know if you look at something like
jurgen klopp who's one of the best
leaders you know when they score a goal
he goes absolutely quickly when they
lose he's upset
and uh you know i think that people buy
into that passion
and people buy into that however you
know you've got to harness it in the
right way
um i think when i first started off as a
leader a lot of my management was based
on feeling and based on emotion and
based on what i was thinking and i
didn't ever have any evidence or clarity
or transparency around what i expected
and what the goals were um and you know
i think that
when you're small and you're a team of
two or three and they know you and they
get you
it's it's fine but you know when you get
to a team of above six or seven or eight
um you're not so involved in everybody
everybody doesn't know you as well as
those people who have perhaps grown with
you and seen some good times it makes it
really hard and and you know
there's nothing more embarrassing than
sitting in front of somebody and you
know you criticizing them and then
saying them saying where's the evidence
for that and you're just like i don't
know i just got a i just got a feeling
yeah you know if you're just like i've
sat down here are your numbers i've
analyzed your calls um here's what
you're missing out um
and
by the way you're not uh you're not
doing enough of this or enough of that
because i can see that the month before
you had a good result on this etc then
um
you know that that's when it's tangible
and it can give something to to work
from
um
so
yeah i think that that's that was a big
learning curve is managing from um
emotion works to a point but um you know
you do also need a lot of tangible
evidence stuff uh because i i do think
that you know people buy into people who
are passionate and a little bit
emotional and
where their heart hell must leave uh and
i'm just a you know management robot who
just sits and looks at numbers in the
sheets no one no one likes that guy no
one yeah what
what you're also saying is being you
you're being authentic you would like
being true to yourself and i think what
i really took from what you just said
there is which i think sometimes can be
a challenge or sometimes doesn't
communicate that can have a real impact
is like making like how many if you
listen to this right now and you have a
small or growing team like how many of
your consultants actually know what the
standards are like do you do they know
what is expected of them if they don't
then there's there's obviously clearly
going to be some bumps and some
challenges right because if the
consultant goes well i've done this and
in your head you're like well i want you
to be here it's like well hang on a
minute like do you know what i mean so i
think that's clearly something that that
just really sort of jumped out with me
when you said that around having clear
understanding and standards on like
where we want people to be striving for
right
guess work
exactly and and you know a lot of people
have like a kpi of 25 phone calls or 20
phone calls or 10 phone calls or however
much but what is the phone call
yeah you like you know
there's got to be some sort of criteria
because if not it's just uh all right
mate you're looking for a new job all
right no i'm not okay see ya oh yeah
i'll add that to my kpi
um and literally you know it took
somebody sitting in front of me and
saying well yeah his here's my a calls
i've already done it after two hours and
they were just literally all like that
to me realizing actually you do need
some clarity around what actually
constitute a call even
um and you know phone time for example
like all right great you've been on the
phone for an hour and a quarter today or
to two candidates well you know that's
not really enough um you know it should
be an hour and a quarter to five or six
candidates but
people don't know that until they're
given the framework and i'd say that's
my kind of third main point about
leadership is um give people a framework
and this is something i learned off a
guy called andrew silito as well um you
know he sat us down as managers and um
was just like um
he gave us basically a puzzle and then
gave us a diagram of the puzzle and and
it was quite simple but the amount of
time it took us to complete it was
amazing because he gave us the framework
and if people don't have that to go off
then they're not going to be able to
solve the puzzle
right so you've got to make sure that
your infrastructure and your process and
your learning and all of that sort of
stuff gives people that framework and i
think something that i created which i'm
really proud of is i created basically a
26 page document on how to recruit from
all of my training sessions i've ever
done i typed them up and um yeah put
them into something called the infracs
um and yeah i think that really gives
people a gold standard and a process and
you know if you go outside of these
lines then you know you're not sticking
to what we believe in and you know
there'll be issues because um yeah this
is what we know and this is what works
um so i think that's also a really
really good part of this framework point
as well yeah no thanks for sharing that
the the next thing that i think sort of
leadership and managers on this journey
can find difficult as well is then like
getting the best out of their team so
like talk to us a bit about that
typically we hear people talk about
really understanding that they had to go
on a bit of a journey and understand
like okay what are my people what what
are my individual people really
motivated by understand that but like
what's been your journey in like
maximizing
like your team and getting the most out
of them because i think a common
challenge that sometimes people can go
through as well
is like you may have yet like marcus
expectations on someone that isn't
marcus right so like yeah you think
about why aren't they doing that like
that's something i would do and that
that isn't quite scalable and isn't
always gonna work right so i don't know
what what's been your journey and like
getting the most out of your team and
keeping them motivated helping them
achieve high performance what does that
look like for you
yeah so i actually learned this quite a
lot from um
from the person i worked with my first
company and the person i worked with
at thor nick who
and i think they were very very similar
characters
and very very similar however one had
compassion nick had compassion he
actually showed he cares
um and the other guy didn't you know
they were both full of energy and lots
of lots of consequences and a bit of
whipping here and there and and you know
a lot of tough chats and and all that
sort of stuff but yeah one in compassion
the other one didn't so i think that
um you know showing people that you care
is really really important and you care
about them not not about just yourself
and that you genuinely want them to do
well and at the end of the day i think i
say this to everyone when i came in i've
had a great journey you know i've
learned so much
i've achieved a lot
so i feel anyway um
but i think that
um
if i don't show that to those people
then i'm not i'm not doing them a favor
i don't think so
yeah i think that that's the biggest
thing for me is that compassionate side
of management just get to know people
show them you care don't treat them as a
number you know
make sure that they are
somebody who you could sit in a part
in a pub with and have a point with and
um you know shoot the [ __ ] before you
hire them because then you you will be
compassionate for that person want them
to do well when they when they are there
yeah um
so i think that's that's the main thing
and yeah there's all the like find out
what people are motivated by find out
what their goals are and you know when
do you want to buy a house in the next
two or three years and oh you want a
gucci or fendi handbag or whatever
you know that that's great it's a bit
shallow
um you know and i think that like
um if you just show people you want
what's best for them then
i think that that's a great way to to
get that buy-in basically no i know it
sounds really basic to show compassion
but it is it's easy to say and there's
another thing to
actually like like deliver it to like
live and breathe every single day to
mean it and it's it's really interesting
actually you say that because i know we
both spoke about this like we're both
big fans of the uh high performance
podcast and
i'm a huge fan of like ben francis in
the gym shot journey i think he's just
super inspirational really down to uh
big on humility and one thing that he
said a lot recently in the podcast i
listened to him about was the ceo that
he brought in he said one of his biggest
assets is like the people management
piece and the thing that's always stuck
with him and you'll hear on the podcast
if you listen to it marcus but basically
it's something along the lines of like
don't ask people how they are if you're
not prepared to listen to the answer and
how many times have you experienced that
where someone goes oh marcus how are you
yeah like
you don't feel like they're listening
you know what i mean and that's the
compassion bit like don't ask how people
are if you're not prepared to listen to
the answer and i think that's what
you're saying
absolutely and that's something i'm
really proud of is that if i took any or
i really hope you know if they listen to
this
but um you know i'd i'd say that if i
sat somebody down the room the first
question i asked them was how are you
they'd give me a completely honest
answer
and i don't i don't i don't want
somebody being positive
for the sake of it i want someone to
give it to me straight how are you
actually feeling and you know what if
you are feeling demotivated um you know
we all go through that
of course we do we all go through slight
lulls even when you know i was i felt
like i was at the top of my game um
billing you know there'd be a month
where
you know it'd be a little bit slower and
you'd have a little bit less interviews
and
whatever but um you know i think that as
long as people can say that to you i
completely agree
i think you know
um that shows that they buy into you and
and that you are compassionate and that
you actually care how they're feeling
and that you will actually listen i
think yeah
so look before we finish here i just
want to touch on like what like what
you're excited about the future
but before we do really quickly i have
to sort of ask like
as i said like early on likes not many
people like many people
will be told like told like this is
where we are today and this is where
we're going but you were the tempo
like four on there on the verge of like
hiring 100 like being 100 people in the
business like
what i guess
what have you taken from this journey so
far and like being part of this sort of
yeah real growth story like what has
helped you
i don't know like i don't know what
comes up when we think of like going
from 10 people to 98 people like i don't
know what have been some of the maybe
key highlights or key things that i
guess you're never going to forget in in
this journey
yeah so i think the um
the feeling of
just constantly doing placements and
waking up in the morning a cv is in your
inbox and you're just like i know that
makes that job make sense to that person
i'm gonna place them i'll i'll never
forget that feeling and it kind of went
on for two years and it is you know it's
you feel a bit unstoppable like it is a
brilliant feeling um
and then i think the the next
the next thing i'll take from it is you
know really growing and being
entrepreneurial in a business and you
know i was lucky enough to not just
stick within one
vertical my whole career i've managed to
kind of go to two or three or four or
five or six seven different industries
and help grow teams within
within that and i think that that's been
a great thing like replicating the
process but also flexing it depending on
the industry
is amazing and i think that um you know
like
giving
like
giving people the opportunity to
um
i don't know surprise you a little bit
like you know it's not all about you as
a leader it's about them and um
you know i'm probably still guilty of it
now sometimes is trying to maybe take a
little bit too much control and not
really giving enough out to the guys and
and and that sort of thing and something
i'm working on a lot but you know people
will come up with some absolute goals
and your idea isn't always the best idea
as a leader so you know create a
create a committee create a um
a platform where people can come up to
you and and uh share your ideas and and
be entrepreneurial themselves i think
yeah i love that
and then before i asked you a bit about
what you were excited about
may
i get this obviously this i've this
totally been inspired by like the high
performance podcast but just interested
as this as as these teams have been
growing the business has been grown what
would you say like the free
non-negotiables that
everyone sort of a bias who lives to on
on the culture side as the cisco just
super interested do you think everyone
lives by stands by
yeah so i think um
[Music]
firstly no one's bigger than the club
it's such a cliche such a cliche but
literally like um you know you're never
too big to sweep the sheds at the end of
the day you can be a team leader but um
you know you've still got to turn up to
work on time and yeah yeah you can be
doing deal upon deal upon deal but
you've got to think that you're a role
model within that business and you know
if you're behaving like that and you're
the top biller you know some rookies
coming in is going to see that person
and just be like
well hold on they're behaving like that
i can get to that point eventually no
so i think that that that's definitely
the main thing is to keep up with
standards throughout
no matter how big or successful that you
get
um i think the second thing is always
grow if not you're gonna die
um you know i think that um when you
bring new people into a business um
there is a fresh kind of perspective
fresh bit of accountability and uh
everyone kind of ups their game a little
bit because
you know whether they're a graduate or
whether they're an experienced hire um
you know they'll they'll come in and
they'll hit the ground running and then
other people will also hit the ground
running so if you're if you're not
growing you're dying if you're not
seeing the platform to grow within the
industry that you're in and the market
that you're in
go and do something about it you know
go and look at another sector go and
deep dive into where the investments are
being made all over the world off the
back of kovitz i think that that's a
really really important important thing
and i think the third one is probably
the the framework point
um i'm going to give you a fourth one as
well on the second
third one
third one the framework point um you
know give people a framework and they'll
and and set people up to succeed
basically and and they'll do really well
um and then the fourth one is
when things aren't going your way and
you know you you've got
a bit of adversity or you know you've
had a tough couple of months
look in the mirror don't blame external
factors you know
um we touched we touched someone earlier
take responsibility for what you're
doing you know if you've had 40 calls
and
you know you've not got a cv in or you
know you've had
five offers rejected that's not all down
to bad luck
you know you
you need to really really look at what
you're doing and take responsibility and
same for me as a manager you know if
you've had a tough month how did you set
your team up with not the month before
um you know my business wasn't crap the
month before they did 10 grand yields or
whatever but now you know we've dropped
off a bit so why was that ask yourself a
question come up with a plan make it
better and uh yeah go into the next
month or the next week or next day you
know really really um trying to improve
on that point after looking in the
mirror
love it look final question what are you
excited about for them what's on the
horizon obviously
yeah been there for seven years now
obviously being there for a decade is
going to be an exciting milestone for
you like what you when you think of the
future at four what what do you see what
are you excited about
well i think across the whole business
you know we've um what we've started to
do is hire some
uh you know we've always been quite
organic taken a lot of graduates we've
now started to hire some really good
people uh experienced people and i think
that what's great is that um you know
they've come into our environment and
our culture and they've they've hit the
ground running and i think it's because
they really like that i'm not selling it
by the way but um you know i think they
really really like their culture so i
think that they can really really
um kick on within thor and take us to
the next level and then when we do hire
more graduates which will happen
throughout the next year um you know
they will be able to learn even more
from those people so i'm really really
excited about that definitely and i
think within my unit
within engineering i feel like we're in
such a good niche and good vertical and
the strategy is really set to kick on
for the next year to really smash it out
of the park and see some more growth um
i think that we've got some amazingly
talented individuals in my team
they know the process they know what to
do
now they just have to go out and do it
and uh you know just had a lot of work
on our strategy over the last couple of
months but i really really feel like
they're in a good place to smash it up
now in the next year or so
brilliant look i think i absolutely love
your passion
and really excited to see how
things evolve in the next couple years
but being on such a great journey from
yeah not doing many deals last couple of
years but
persevered made that happen and been an
absolute pleasure handling on the
podcast marcus thanks a lot
thanks very much